Now I want to tell you a story
It is written for 4 year olds, but I would like to see it
from a different perspective
and see if you can imagine exactly what it really counts
Dragons do not exist
We all know that. One dragon is
a thought-based being. reptilian
horrible, immortal
breathe fire
collects gold
It's a strange collection of features
Why in the world should something terrible and ancient
Have a treasure
Billy Bixby was surprised when he woke up
one morning and discovered a dragon in his room
It was a little dragon the size of a kitten
The dragon was happy with his tail
When Billy patted it upside down
In Chinese mythology
Is the dragon a positive figure
In European mythology
is a draw something you confront in battle and
destroy. Or something you confront in battle
and build something out of the remains of the dragon
Billy went down to tell his mother
"Dragons do not exist," Billy's mother said
and she sounded like she meant it
My daughter once had a nightmare
She was about 4 years old
It was at the time when she began to notice graffiti and
and waste on the street, which annoyed her
She did not understand the graffiti's motivation
and she did not like the waste
There was a mess in the world
The reason she was sensitive to it as a child
was that children are very dependent on order
And the reason is
that their level of competence is quite low
so they do not like things being messed with. So, for example
small children may not like if you play with them and
and changes the rules of the doctor. They may not like it at all
They think it is immoral
to shake around with the game rules
... She came into our bedroom
and said "dad i had a nightmare"
Nightmares do not exist, like dragons. Dreams are
not real. Which makes one wonder why
why we saw dreams 6-8 hours every night
and why they exist
in all animals right down to the amphibians
she said "I dreamed there was a clean brook"
"but in the brook there was a lot of waste and that made me scared"
"so i woke up"
I said "close your eyes and imagine the brook"
"it's full of waste. What do you want to do about it?"
She said "I have to take the waste out of the creek"
I said "ok, imagine you clean the cymbal"
She settled down and went in to sleep
Why? FOr Dreams focuses on threats. We know that
They present you with threats you have not been able to do something about
There is a part of the brain that follows threats
And that part isn't really that clever
it just says "see here is a problem"
And waiting for the rest of the brain to come up with a solution
and if there is no solution, the problem is only produced again and again and again
So people who, for example, have PTSD
It has been traumatized by the contact with something unexpected
Dreaming of the same tragedy for an eternity
Until they find a solution
and they find a solution by seeing it in the face and living it
repeatedly. Volunteer.
So from that story you might think
that by suggesting to his 4 year old
that her dreams are not real
And what they represent is not genuine because you cannot touch them
Maybe not the best solution to the problem
Billy has got the long end from the start
The dragon whispered when Billy patted it upside down
Billy took down to tell his mother about it. "dragons do not exist"
Said Billy's mother
and she sounded like she meant it
So there's a dragon in this house
Then you might think
How often have you gone into a house with a dragon?
My guess is if you don't take this
history literally and permits itself
to think metaphorically
you have been in dozens of houses with lots of dragons
who have all been ignored with great effort by those who lived there
Billy went up to his room and put on clothes
The dragon came close to Billy in a friendly manner
and it wailed, but Billy did not pat it
For if something does not exist, it is stupid to pat it up
Billy washed himself and went down to the breakfast table
The dragon went along and was bigger now, like a dog
Billy sat down at the table
The dragon sat on the table
That was not allowed
But Billy's mother couldn't do anything
for she had all told that dragons did not exist
and if something does not exist, one cannot say that it must not sit on the table
Sometimes I visit friends
for dinner. And the little children are not sitting at the table
They sit on the table or run around the table
or pull things down from the table
or pull things off the shelves
the whole house saw the parents
are so busy that they can't talk together
Under the conditions, one must consider
whether it is a child or a dragon
and you can also consider about the dragon
Is great and unruly
because the parents will not admit it exists
Mom made pancakes for Billy
But devour them all. Mother made more
But it also devoured them. Mother continued
until there was no more dough. Billy only got one
But he said it was exactly what he wanted
One of my acquaintances in Boston
took his son over to our house for baby sitting
His babysitter had just been in an accident
so he was sent from house to house by friends who could look after him
His reputation was not very good. He was about 4 years old
He came to our house in the morning
She said he probably doesn't eat anything all day, but that's okay
I thought "No"
He is 4 years old if he does not eat all day
It is not okay for if children do not eat
If they do not eat and sleep, they are terrible
It's not okay that he doesn't eat
Perhaps there is a dragon associated with him?
that prevents him from eating
So I came home for dinner, my wife had the kids
the 4-5 other children in the house
played while he was standing in the corner
completely isolated
He looked upset. So I pricked him
If you dot a child a little
They do that, though
sooner or later they bleed and smile
not him here. He didn't want to play with me. Basta
He had already learned
that adults should be ignored
or that adults were dangerous. He didn't want to let an adult
into his world. So that was absolutely certain
one dragon with the little boy, and the one eating his pancakes
Billy went up to brush his teeth
The suit that was bigger lay down to sleep in the hallway
When Billy came down, the dragon had grown so big
that it filled the whole time
Billy had to go through the living room to get to his mother
I didn't know that dragons are growing so fast
"Dragons do not exist," said his mother determined
The cleaning took all morning
because the dragon was in the way
so one had to climb out of windows to get from room to room
When you have visited a home with a dragon
hiding under the blanket
and no one says anything about it, and you think
How long does it take to do something quite simply
In a house that is crowded
with unresolved issues? Forever?!
Doing something quite simply in such a house
such as breakfast
or preparing a meal is almost impossible. Why?
Because something is going on
in the house being ignored
with great effort over a long period of time
and that has therefore become enormous
that it fills it all
At midday, the dragon filled the whole house
The head stuck out of the front door, the tail out of the back door
and every room
had some of the dragon in it
When the dragon woke up, it was hungry
a bread truck drove past
fresh bread could not withstand the dragon
it ran down the street after the car truck and the house followed
like a snail house
The postman was on his way
by post when the house passed by
He chased their house a few streets
but couldn't catch it
Then Mr. Bixby came home for breakfast
He first noticed that the house was gone
Fortunately, a neighbor could tell in what direction it had run
This kind of thing also happens quite often
People don't really notice what is happening
and they come home one day and the house is gone
What does it mean?
Perhaps their children have become completely alienated
or their wife has decided "suddenly"
But of course not so sudden
to leave them. Why?
According to this story
is because something you ignored was allowed to grow in the house
Mr. Bixby sat down in the car and drove out looking for the house
He looked at all the houses on the road
Eventually he saw one so familiar
Billy and Mrs Bixby waved from the 1st floor
In the 1890s in India
when building houses, a local would want
priest or equivalent
come and lay the first stone in the foundation. NP he did this
he would take a big pole and
hammer it into the ground. The reason he did this
where the foundation was to be built
was to keep the big dragon lurking underground
hammered down so it couldn't get up
and shattering the house
That means the same as
when in the New Testament stands
that one should not build his foundation on sand
Then it doesn't matter how good the house is
How well constructed or rich
If the foundation is on sand
or on top of a dragon, there is nothing in the house
who ever gets well
and the prosperity the house may look outward to
is just a facade
Mr. Bixby climbed the dragon's head and into the window
How did this happen? He asked
It was the dragon said Billy
They do not exist, Mother began
but there is a dragon insisted Billy. A great one
and Billy patted it upside down
The dragon was happy with the tail
and even faster than it had grown, the dragon became smaller
Soon it was the size of a kitten again
I have nothing against dragons on this size said mother
Why was it so great
I'm not sure Billy said
But maybe it just wanted to be noticed